[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN PERSON: Give me
one minute and I'll
show you how Filestore can help
you manage your file system.
Filestore is a managed file
storage service for apps
that require a file system
interface and a shared file
system for data.
It gives users a simple,
native experience
for standing up managed
network-attached storage
with their VM instances in
Compute Engine and Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Filestore offers low
latency for file operations
so it's perfect for workloads
like data analytics, media
rendering, genomics processing,
or other media-intensive
application.
You can pick a performance
tier and the storage capacity
you need with
Filestore, which enables
you to tune your file system
for a particular workload.
Use Cloud Console, the
API, or simple gcloud
commands to create a
Filestore instance.
Applications across
your organization
probably need to access
and share common datasets.
You can host file
content in Filestore
and enable shared
access to that data.
Filestore helps creators, like
graphic designers and video
editors, access shared storage
to manipulate and produce
large files.
So next time you're looking
to manage files, take a minute
to look at Filestore.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/filestore.